oui non bien sûr que je peux garder des
ballons mais enfin vous exagérez casimir
et toi vous m'aviez produits de rentrer
après le déjeuner
quoi vous avez bien égal que casimir am
les autos tamponneuses joue
enfin d'accord
à tout à l'heure
un jour vous êtes là c'est françois qui
me téléphonait ils sont à la fête
foraine casimir est lui il s'amuse
tellement que ils ne rendent que ce soir
alors qu'il m'avait promis de rentrer
tout à l'heure ce n'est pas très drôle
enfin
s'ils s'amusent
quel est cet individu inquiète donc que
je n'ai jamais fait de lille
s'est muré france souhaite moi ce serait
plus tranquille fait pas de bruit
4 vous comme vous voulez vous je vous ai
demandé au travers de bruit
vous ne savez pas trop bas que je suis
championne de judo
absolument c'est moi algret
vous êtes vous déguisez vous voulez
faire signer un nouveau contrat à
casimir non pas du tout je cache
cache je suis poursuivi
poursuivi par elle et la terreur de lyon
d'enfants laurie blu ray mais chut
nous répétions un petit numéro de music
hall pour la fête de l'île aux enfants
quand tout à coup elle a glissé son pied
sous le mien juste au moment où se
terminait un merveilleux sociale
la pauvre elle a dû avoir très mal en
tout cas beaucoup que
ça c'est bien beau mais vous avez vous
utilisé je vous reconnais
vous lassez pas pressé et bien ça va
prendre un peu vous vous rendez vous
oh lalala lalala
[Musique]
dans les jardins
potagers
[Musique]
twitter
tout qu'est ce que tu lis
[Musique]
il ya quelque chose qui m'énerve c'est
bien me sentir quelqu'un qui lit par
dessus mon épaule
excuse moi excuse moi on est tombé sur
l'épaule
sur les poules sont ni poule vous avez
déjà vu une tortue avec des épaules vous
[Musique]
je vais vous conter
l'histoire du cataplasme
vous dans dans la campagne non mais
malade
ils tous beaucoup comme moi aux ennuis
taille alors sa femme sa famille
s'inquiète beaucoup et fait venir le
médecin parce que les meuleuses son mari
est malade donc à devenir le maître et
mes médecins qu'est ce qu'il fait pour
l'anc est malade et enfants et qui
touche beaucoup il leur donne quant à ta
place
pour guérir donc le mari mais
malheureusement la pharmacie pour
acheter des quatre places est très loin
de la maison où habite la fin élan qui
tente un petit malade alors la femme se
dit el arabi dit comme ça mais je suis
très bonne cuisinière et ont fait de
tintin pincemi je vais faire des crêpes
c'est des bonnes crêpes du sucre alors
elle fait la patte comme ça un fait
plein de pintes jacques despons plafond
d'un lien encore accroché par la team la
faune et la flore des bonnes très bien
chaude et un est parfaitement perçu a
dit que cela fera la sphère annonces du
jour après du nom trois jours après par
an
trois jours après le médecin revient et
il dit alors madame les cataplasmes
ont-ils fait leur effet
oui docteur dit la femme mon mari en a
mangé 40 et maintenant
il va tout à fait bien
une petite cuillère
le sucre le sucre
voilà qui semble en train de
vous outre julie le thé est servi
c'est vraiment gentil de m'avoir invité
bon hein tu sais j'avais fait itron de
thé alors c'était bête de laisser père
en tout cas ça tombe bien parce que je
me sentais triste et j'avais besoin de
parler à un ami
atr qu'il tombait sur les petits gâteaux
on a tout est gâché je suis désolé
mais quand l'on enfin
et bien écoute je te propose de faire
une bonne action
les bonnes actions c'est rare moins
amusant en vain si ça fait plaisir
22.5 victimes et bien voilà et mais futé
et monsieur travelling se sont fâchés
parce qu'il lui a écrasé un pied en
répétant un pas de danse
en c'est la première bonne nouvelle de
la journée
alors il faut que tu m'aides à les
réconcilier
quoi
bon c'est d'un cran je crois que j'ai
une idée
c'est merveilleux je viens de recevoir
une lettre du directeur de l'opéra il
m'a demandé de l'attendre ici même
c'est lui s'est amusé rendez vous avec
le directeur de l'opéra soyez assez
gentil pour faire évacuer cette pimbêche
j'ai rendez-vous moi aussi ça
m'étonnerait qu'on grossier personnage
et
de vous disputer je suis le directeur de
l'opéra c'est le dire et c'est moi qui
nous est venue
silence j'étais venu pour écouter votre
duo mais quand je vois que vous ne vous
entendez plus alors je ne peux en garde
et ni l'un ni l'autre n'est pas du tout
c'est le directeur mademoiselle fut
témoin nous sommes de grands amis mais
jade deux réussites ravignat
non je veux bien dit mickey et voir
votre duo
j'ai couru le monde entier je voulais
être milliardaire
l'argent je le modèle non des chars ils
ne me croyaient s'admirer
mais vous j'ai compris qu'on ne peut
vivre solitaire chacun me tester deux
mois on se méfiait c'était tout seul et
je souffre ac rien ne vaut les amis
c'est moi qui vous le dit adieu solitude
ici je veux aspects
votre amitié me plaît gardez moi s'il
vous plaît
je ferai d'humour pour chasser l efo
c'est une certitude
il faut tout partagé parfois des sondes
rien n'est plus beau que l'ami type
[Musique]
je voulais et sans pitié
que l'on fasse tous mes caprices pour
tous je décide est jamais je ne serai et
je me croyais respecter
les tous les gens redoutaient
ma poignée de main est triste
et lorsque ja prochaine chacun se
détournaient personne ne me salaires
rien nouveau dit c'est moi
et vous le dit
adieu la solitude
ici je veux rester votre amitié me plaît
gardez moi s'il vous plaît
je ferai ce qu'il faut pour chasser mené
défaut c'est une certitude
il faut tout partagé par pouvoir et
cendrés
rien n'est plus beau que l'amitié rien
ne vaut des amis c'est moi qui vous le
dis adieu la série qu
ici je veux rester votre amitié me plaît
gardez moi s'il vous plaît
je ferai ce qu'il prouve pour chasser
vrai des fours études
[Musique]
il faut tout partagé parfois et centrait
rien n'est plus beau que l'amitié
[Musique]
du tout mais produit tout à ça moi ou
d'être devenus amis qu sic ou même plus
important qu'un contrat à l'opéra
[Musique]